[Musique]
encore
il peut y avoir au moins 24 ans pour se
présenter au sénat
l'âge moyen des sénateurs est de 62 ans
en début de mandat à 29 ans david
rachline est le plus jeune de
l'hémicycle le doyen serge dassault est
lui âgé de 92 ans le sénat c'est trois
quarts d'hommes et un quart de femmes la
représentation des femmes augmente très
légèrement avec le renouvellement mais
reste faible
première profession représentée dans
l'hémicycle enseignants un quart des
sénateurs exerce ce métier
les autres fonctionnaires représente 16%
du palais du luxembourg
le sénat s'est aussi 38 cadre 16
agriculteurs et seulement un ouvrier
enfin les deux tiers des sénateurs
existe au moins un mandat local 130
d'entre eux sont maires présidents de
conseil départemental ou de régions vont
devoir choisir entre le sénat et leur
mandat local en raison de la loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats
à